eric swallow is calling for more
investigations and more hearings he was
just
talking about how god is a woman during
this
yes uh during uh you know some of his
testimony that he was on right now
and now nancy pelosi is calling from for
9 11
style commission into the january 6th
insurgency
so they're not going to stop talking
about this at all because this is the
only card that they have
a lot of americans are asking them like
hey you promised us a lot of stuff show
us what you got
you're in power you have the house you
have the senate you have the presidency
what can you do for the american people
and they're like
not eleven commission on donald trump do
you want that
and people are like uh no i don't want
that that doesn't interest me
what can you do for me this is the
american people are asking that and it's
going to become more tumultuous as we
move forward
this is what i love about what the
democrats are doing right now
there's a lot of pundits on the left
that they love projecting what's going
on with democrats onto republicans
and it's funny because the republicans
don't do anything you know i mean like
mitch mcconnell
is he what is he vote not guilty but
then complains trump was guilty it's
like clearly the dude's not doing
anything
republican leadership at this point is
an oxymoron but the democrats like to
claim that republicans don't have any
real policies
that's why they're not doing anything
the democrats have no real policies
that's why all they keep doing is saying
orange man bad well after the orange
man's gone
it's been a month seriously and now they
want to do a new commission
911 style commission to investigate the
capital breach is the next step
oh is it but why impeachment's over
what's the point
yeah the national guard's still in dc
right
i mean i was i left i was there briefly
and i still saw they had all the fences
and the barbed wire
it was a day of freezing rain it looked
absolutely miserable
um i think that was the day that the
verdict was announced they're still
there they've still militarized the
capital
they're going to be there until march
yeah like for what
i heard they're gonna be there longer
actually so i can't remember who exactly
tweeted this joke
but they said something about
the national guard is they're now saying
the national guard will remain in dc
until the fall
the fall of what i'd be so pissed if i
was in the national guard and they're
like you just need to stand out here
buy this barbecue fire fence and sleep
in the parking garage
and share a bathroom one bathroom with
five thousand other individuals
they're still doing it well so i don't i
don't know if exactly right now but i
remember after
the big controversy was they were making
like 5 000 guardsmen
take breaks or like sleep in a parking
garage with one power outlet and two
toilets
and then there was a big uproar oh how
dare they and then like a week ago they
were like yeah they're still there
like they never got them out the news
cycle just walked away and everyone
forgot about these people
but i've heard from people who you know
who uh
friends of friends of people in the
guard would say that they're they're
extremely demoralized
it's like but i mean i mean think about
that demoralization has to be swimming
across this country
just across the board and the the the
issue with that is i'm sure everyone's
familiar with yuri besmanov
he talked about you know that sort of
kgb yeah i think i feel like i've seen
that clip on youtube
it's just it's sent 50 billion times to
us all day every day but he talks about
demoralization
and what happens when people are
completely demoralized
and they feel like the system doesn't
work anymore there's no justice nancy
pelosi doing this commission
is probably the stupidest and most
deranged thing i've ever heard
to tell the american people at a time
when the news report i think was reuters
1400 checks will hold you over until
july
like in what world will that be enough
for anybody but don't worry
don't worry i know you're all stressed
you can't pay your rent
the moratorium and eviction is gonna be
ending soon we're gonna see
millions of evictions but it's okay
nancy pelosi has promised
a 911 style commission on several the
several hundred people who walked
who stormed their way into the capitol
building and uh
while you're sleeping outside you can
rest easy knowing
the full details of what happened on
january 6. it won't change anything in
your life
it won't change who the president is it
won't give you any food
but it's the right ideology hey there
hey hey don't don't be all negative at
least the pharma industrial complex is
going to have
more profits with their insulin you know
it's not all
bad so why would they have more profits
from their insulin because uh of the
rule that uh biden overturned you know
you know what that actually makes sense
because i was gonna say they were gonna
have less profits
because once they evict the people who
are diabetic and they can't have a
refrigerator because
they'll be living outside for their
insulin they'll die so then how do they
make up that
loss of profits from the dead people
jack the price back up yeah
yeah cuomo style it's not all bad the
military industrial complex is also
going to be happy as nato just announced
that they're not going to be leaving
afghanistan
anytime soon today as well thank the
lord
i was really worried you know uh i've
long said when people i see all these
activists complaining with the military
industrial complex in american empire
and i'm like
who's gonna bomb the kids if we don't do
it and then when when trump uses
the the abraham accords bringing peace
to the middle east
thank our lucky stars of him i know
that's right
praise be to biden bringing in those
drones and keeping us in afghanistan for
what reason
i'm not entirely sure but apparently
they told us it needs to be done uh
so most of my life we've been in
afghanistan yeah more than half of my
whole life
yeah there's fathers and sons fighting
alongside each other
in afghanistan it's the longest war in
american history
and where does the money go where does
the money go where does all the opium
come from
the 90 of the world's opium where does
it come from it's a money toilet
yeah and the stories that i've heard
because i've heard from a lot of
you know soldiers that were over there
especially when it comes to
you know we can't even talk about some
of the stuff here that the soldiers
caught and
soldiers were punished in the the united
states for exposing
uh the abuse of children in afghanistan
and trying to stop it in afghanistan
uh so it's just an absolutely
horrible thing to be ins and be in i
understand you're hurting
and and this kind of stuff stresses you
out makes you angry but did you know
that nancy pelosi is putting together a
911 style commission on the people who
stormed the capital feels good
it's the same type of we were just
talking about the new york times in
their own naval gazing being constantly
consumed by their own internal hr drama
right okay congress is now constantly
internally consumed by its own think
about like they spent their time at
trying to expel marjorie taylor green
impeaching the president 911 commissions
like
it's all drama it's all reality tv
it's just all internal hr matters
basically within the government as
opposed to doing things
stop being able to perform their
function i almost want to run for office
and when people like what do you stand
for i just be like i'm going to just
build a shed
for this one guy just that that's it i'm
gonna i'm gonna use all of my time
to go like just to local people's houses
and help them with their chores
if you elect me i will help you with
your chores because at least then your
taxpayer dollars goes towards something
productive
because i can't i can't tell you what
these people are doing right i might not
be there to vote on whatever stupid
garbage bill they're proposing but i
assure you this
if i ever did run i'd literally just
weed your garden
put up some fences for you walk your dog
because then you know your tax dollars
are at least
getting you some public service right i
mean how hard is it like this is the
easiest government program ever
like just give people money like they
did it already they know how to do it
they just write a check they use the
whatever technology they did to put the
money in your bank well they even
fumbled that
especially with with even the first oh
yeah there was multiple trials there was
different layers there's different time
periods when people got
their checks so the government can't
even send you a check correctly
what makes you think they should run
your medical health care
right what makes you think that they
should be in charge of anything in
their life they were giving dead people
money and they were giving money to
non-citizens overseas
like how does it happen that some dude
in a different country wakes up like
the american government gave me money
for somebody we have a social security
number
all of us it's so easy they have the
data all they have to do is literally be
like okay yeah send them a check oh live
dead check
that's it they can't even do they can't
tell you
they can't run the post office and guess
what all of government runs that way
spend spend a few days spend a few hours
even at your local dmv and imagine
these central controllers wanting to
control every aspect of your life
it would scare the bejesus out of you
that's the one thing i don't get
like the people who advocate for
universal healthcare like bernie sanders
does
do they not remember going to the dmv
once yeah
i mean you know that's there's all sorts
of problems that lead to government
incompetence and
and it gets back to the point i was
making earlier there's not a good way to
punish them for lying
i think perhaps you know there's two big
disciplines on our public companies
that and our regulatory system kind of
works for this right the first
discipline is they have to make money
and the second is they have to tell the
truth every three quarters or they risk
i mean they don't always do it but
they're like under a legal obligation to
and they have to file a report that's
examined by
you know stock market investors i want
public lashings
you're a politician you lie you have to
go to the center of the city
and you get lashed by a random citizen
no one wins the lottery the constituent
yeah he's given the cat of nine tails
yes and then you get to
whoop the politicians but in the
buttocks all right
i'll clarify though because i said that
in somalia by the way i said the people
like bernie sanders because
i actually would like i personally would
like some kind of universal basic health
care
but bernie sanders wants to abolish
private health care i think so long as
you have that competition and you have
that choice
i think we'll be okay but i also think
before you can advocate for any before
you can implement any kind of major
social reform
you've got to weed out the corruption
and i think that's the biggest wall
blocking legitimate social programs and
social reform
i mean if you can't even give people two
thousand dollar checks how on earth are
you gonna do brain surgery on them like
like yeah not uh government's not
competent enough to do this
and that's the the you know the problem
is like when the programs first start
when the government first comes in
there's somebody with a decent idea that
makes sense to a lot of people
but businesses have to fight to survive
they have to make sense
a business has to be able to generate
revenue and profit to hire more people
and grow and if they can they collapse
government when they just can't do it
they just send more people with guns to
collect more taxes
and then pump more money into something
that's not working yeah so
that's always been my thing i like the
idea of social programs the problem is
well the first question is can they ever
be implemented properly or is the issue
there needs to be an expiration date on
all of them period
i mean you just you have to think about
how you use government and trying to
like
keep whatever it's doing within its core
competency like when i think about for
example
you know what should big tech law look
like you know what i mean i'm advocating
a bigger
governmental role in regulating twitter
and facebook etc well
i'm like okay so we want we want civil
rights style litigation that allows
people to go to court
and pursue their rights like essentially
sue the
the companies because we have courts
they work they they know how to issue
orders and get people to comply with
them
like that's a core competency of
government when you're saying oh
government should literally run the
health care system
you're way outside the government's core
competency thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you